crack along well let's go over the page
and have a good question 15 now again
for the next couple of questions there
are some bits where there is a lot of
writing so I've written already in place
so you don't have to wait for me I'm a
very slow writer but we'll talk about
what I've written and some of the
different ways that you could have
answered these questions as well so you
got enrico and he's decided to conduct a
study to examine the relationship
between students abilities in these two
different klas these two key learning
areas in order to conduct his study
Enrico's requested records of all
students scores from the school so one
of the really important issues that we
need to think about in using statistical
measures is their ethical considerations
so you can see the school is concerned
with the privacy implications of the
request give a reason why they may be
concerned and suggest a remedy so here's
what I've written and most students had
a response like this the school may be
concerned because students have the
right to keep their own scores private
and that's kind of the key there that
each person kind of has ownership over
their own score the scores in general no
one's data but the particular scores
like saying I scored 30% and you scored
75% you having that piece of data is not
something that belongs to me or
vice-versa so that's why it's about
keeping their own scores private and
it's personal data so the way to address
this concern would be one of the ways is
to supply the scores without names or
perhaps without even their class
attached to them so we call that
anonymizing the data and that way what
you've got is an aggregated set of data
it's just like a big clump of data and
you can take all this belongs to this
person this belongs to another person
people can't be identified by the data
that you can see here in this data set
that's provided to Enrico so that's what
I suggested let's have a look at the
next part it says Enrico was granted
access to the data and input it into a
spreadsheet and this is the scatterplot
that he created all right sketch a line
of best fit by eye on the scatterplot
below so since we're scat doing this by
eye we know it's not going to be exactly
accurate but we do want to number one
you know make sure that the
best fit that we draw it matches the the
gradient of what you would expect the
line of best fit to do so if for example
you draw a line that had a positive
gradient that is clearly not fitting
most of the data so that's a bit of a
dud and then secondly noticing it okay
if we want to have a negative line of
best fit here we also want to make sure
that roughly the same amount of data
points are above the data line of best
fit rather and the same are below so for
example if I draw a line like this the
gradient is correct but you can see that
there's a lot missing on the bottom
you've got hardly any of the scores down
there and the vast majority of scores
are above so if I draw a line roughly
I'm gonna expect it's gonna be somewhere
around I'm pretty happy with that yeah
okay now I talked about the errors
before of getting the gradient wrong or
perhaps getting too many points above or
below another common error was just to
take the leftmost data point and to join
it to the rightmost data point if I get
rid of the blue line that I drew you can
see it's a it's a very easy mistake to
make it because it looks roughly right
but it's clearly got more data points
above than below so let's say I get rid
of that one there we go so this is what
I'm going to use and that's my line of
best fit Part C says use your line of
best fit to estimate an English score if
the math score was 90 and then we have
some follow-on questions after that
so let's find our math score of 90 and
see where it meets our line of best fit
so the math scores are the horizontal
axis here so here's 90 it's nice and
easily identified so if I go up from 90
all the way up to the line of best fit
it roughly collides there and then what
I'm going to do is match that with a
data point on the vertical axis the
English scores so I'm going to draw all
the way across alright so what do you
got there
it's worth pointing out that everyone's
going to draw a slightly different line
of best fit and that's fine so your line
of best fit may not look exactly like
this and your estimate as a result may
not look exactly like mine looking at
the scores there
looks like something between 58 and 59
so I'm going to say the English score
I'm using a pen that's too fat let's fix
that the English score estimated is
approximately 59 now that's only the
first part of this question we need to
have a look at what the rest of it's
asking it says is this a valid estimate
and then give reasons for your our time
and this is what really matters this is
what really counts it's your ability not
just to calculate statistics but to
interpret them and then use them
appropriately
is it a valid estimate now this data set
has actually been crafted deliberately
so that like in the real world you
actually could answer in more than one
way and provide justification in more
than one way that actually you know
would be sound reasoning so let me give
you an example of why you might say yes
you might reason yes this is a valid
estimate because this kind of estimate
that we've done is what we call
interpolation interpolation is when
you're having a look within your data
set as opposed to extrapolation which is
when you're looking outside your data
set so an example of looking outside
your data set in this case would be what
if I had a student who scored ten on
their math score ten is very very low
it's so low that it's beyond where I
have actual data points you can see my
my lowest math score here is around 24
or so so if I were to estimate the score
of a person who got a math score of 10
you know my line of best fit says wow
they would have done astronomically well
in English but is that valid when it
comes to extrapolation it's very
difficult to say because where the data
has where there is no data point and
there may be some other trend that takes
over
you know this line maybe it actually
comes down if I had more data points so
it's unclear because I don't possess the
data there but in this case the estimate
that I'm making is not extrapolation its
interpolation within the data set I've
got data points below
I've got data points above so I could
say yes because interpolation is more
accurate than extrapolation so that
could be a way pardon my messy writing
view that could be a way that you
provided the answer yes and then
reasoned it however like I pointed out
you actually if you look closely at this
data it's been crafted a way that you
could have said no and I'm just going to
explain that to you right now for two
reasons number one if you have a look up
in the top right hand corner of this
graph let me just give you some ease
unnecessary lines here the outlook in
this top right hand corner of the graph
we have some outliers these are data
points that are very very far away from
the line of best fit they're nowhere
near in fact and what they represent is
people who've done really well in maths
and they've also done really well in
English and I bet you have some friends
who would just like this or maybe you're
that friend now for that reason if you
have a look here this is kind of gap in
the data set if I get rid of all these
lines for a brief moment here you can
see in here the point where I'm trying
to make a prediction for that score of
90 it just so happens that all of the
actual data points all the actual
students you've got scores around there
they did really well in English not
really badly so to be able to say oh if
you got a math score of 90 you
definitely got an English score of 59 um
isn't borne out by the students who
actually got marks around 90 in
mathematics so because in that gap in
the data and the existence of outliers
and I'm gonna just write that down
outliers are present that indicate you
know what you may have actually got a
high mark in maths and also a high mark
in English at the same time so we might
say they're present a lie is a present
that indicate I'm high achievers in both
subjects that's a bit of a problem with
the data that means you could interpret
it and say this estimate actually we
can't use to predict a student's score
so I'm going to write in both subjects
the other point of course is that it's
not just the data that tells us this
it's also the fact that like I said we
know students
like this assume who is tremendously
well organized
I'm very disciplined as a supportive
home environment all these factors don't
just help you in one subject they help
you in all your subjects and that might
be English and maths
so actually we have very good real-world
data to be able to suggest to us a high
score in one subject could also
correlate it to a high score in both so
that's why you could just as easily have
argued no this is not a valid estimate
the key was did you provide good reasons
for your argument okay so we're coming
toward the end of our statistics
questions let's have a look at Part D
and a will do this from one hit
Enrico found pieces correlation
coefficient to be negative 0.5 and then
he found the equation of his least
squares regression line described the
relationship between English and math
scores at Enrico's school by referring
to the strength of the correlation as
well as the gradient of the regression
line okay so a few things here let's do
it one by one the strength of the
correlation what is the strength of the
correlation here well earlier we were
looking at a question where we got a
correlation coefficient of 0.9 for
something like that which is very high
this correlation coefficient of negative
0.5 well you know it's not completely
random it's not a correlation
coefficient of zero but it's not
sticking closely and you could see that
on the original graph even though they
are very gently gradually following that
line of best fit they're still kind of
all over the place so that's why you can
see I've written here let me just
highlight it in red I've written that
there's a moderate negative correlation
and negative just to remind you from
before
talk about the fact that there's this
gradient that's that's downward as we go
across the graph so it's a moderate
negative correlation what that indicates
is as you can read students do more
poorly in English when they excel in
mathematics and we could have swapped
around the axes and I'm shown that the
vice versa is also true if you mostly do
well in English you don't do all that
well in mathematics for this particular
data set now what that's suggesting a
possible hypothesis a conclusion you
could draw from that is maybe what
students are doing is they're splitting
their time between English and maths so
the more time you spend on one the less
you spend
on the other and so if you invest more
in one you're going to do better there
and that means your performance in the
other one decreases in a corresponding
amount
speaking of corresponding amount the
question also says you should refer to
the gradient of the regression line now
I've talked about the sign of the
gradient I've written about that but I
haven't written about the actual value
of it so you can see here let's
highlight another color the gradient I
read off the equation of the least
squares regression line the gradient is
negative 0.2 and what that means is this
is the rise over run yeah so there's a
rise of negative 0.2 in other words your
marks decrease 0.2 every time you have a
run of 1 so the run here indicates if
you have a look at the original graph
run horizontally that's mathematics
right so one Matz mark as you go to the
right of the graph means you decrease by
0.2 of an English mark roughly speaking
anyway according to this line of best
fit so I didn't write that I ran at a
space here but that would be a better
more accurate way to specifically refer
to the actual gradient that does get
provided to you within the question up
there
all right last statistics question for
the paper can this least squares
regression line be used to predict
mathematics or English scores for
students in other schools give a reason
to justify your response so my
suggestion is that you can't use these
to predict scores in other schools and
that's because there are loads of
factors that influence the prediction of
scores and they differ from one school
to the next perhaps you know one school
has an amazing mathematics faculty and
all the teachers there are brilliant and
you go to a different school and they're
not so great and that's obviously going
to have a huge impact on the performance
of students in mathematics assessment
tasks so because those two factors have
changed completely you wouldn't expect
that you could predict the results of
that school on the results of this
school and it's pretty difficult to
argue an opposite case here because
there are just so many factors in the
opposite direction